does God exist only half of Americans
say a definite yes this is a story on
page 18 if you want to go to it so only
50 of Americans are certain about the
existence of God according to the
General Social Survey this marks a
decline from his from 60 percent over 60
in 2008 indicating a shift in religious
beliefs the survey also reveals that 34
of Americans never attend church the
highest figure recorded in five decades
additionally the number of Americans
claiming no religion has increased from
27 in 2022 up from 19 in 2012 while
religious affiliation and church
attendance continue to decline belief in
some form of higher power remains a
prevalent nearly three-quarters of
Americans believe in life after death
and only seven percent of the population
identifies as atheists despite these
Trends the United States remains
relatively religious compared to other
countries so now here's so so wild about
this
uh half of America more than half of
America believed the Russia collusion
was a real deal so they're willing to
believe a fake narrative like that for
three years and then Durham comes in and
points it out but they have a hard time
believing in God but I have to see it
because I have to see it to believe that
there's a god dude you never saw
anything about Russia but you believed
in Russia delusion with me you have to
see nobody you know about to do was a
little bit of Russian stuff going on no
there was nothing going on it was just
something that you believe in so the
second concern here is the following you
know you know who historically
governments and establishments always
feared who they've feared they've always
feared men and women who believed in a
higher power above the government above
the establishment The Establishment
doesn't like that because the
establishment secretly their desire is
to be God their dream is to be God their
dream is to be feared their dream is
they're jealous they you know it says
God is jealous you know the
establishment is way more jealous than
goddess they want all the attention they
want all the control they want all the
Limelight the difference between a you
know relationship with a God where it's
you know free will you and I get to make
some dumb choices and we do on a daily
basis and we go through that and we pay
the price for it the establishment
doesn't want to give you the free will
The Establishment wants you to do what
they want you to do you do they want to
control you so you know for me there's a
part of this that for some people that
are listening to this everybody falls
into one of three categories you're
either part of the oblivious Camp which
is a big percentage let's say 80 percent
is the oblivious Camp what is the
oblivious Camp man I don't have time to
pay I don't really have an influence you
think my vote really counts I don't
really I just want to have my beer and
watch a football game and you know what
I don't even know what's going on with
Bud Light I go to Coors and Heineken I
don't know what's going on do you
believe this crowd okay number two is
the anti-establishment crowd
historically who is in that camp let's
give some names Andrew Jackson
anti-establishment crowd uh John F
Kennedy the Kennedy's anti-establishment
crowd Ronald Reagan anti-establishment
crowd Ross Perot anti-establishment
crowd Trump anti-establishment crowd
Bernie Sanders anti-establishment crowd
until he caved Elon Musk
anti-establishment crowd I can go on and
on give you so many different names
Ronald Reagan out of all the money that
was spent in his campaign he spent 9.6
percent of his own money to put into it
Trump was 72 percent Ross Pro was 97
percent didn't take any money from
anybody when Kennedy was running his
father said I will use 100 of my life
savings to make sure my son ends up
becoming a president he only ended up
using 50 of the entire campaign I think
it was like 25 million bucks at a time
where Joseph Kennedy was worth 400
million dollars in the 60s so you look
at some of these things and you look at
Hillary Clinton you know how much money
she spent on her campaign zero of her
own money you know how much Biden spent
on the campaign nothing they don't go
and use their own money they use money
from other people they're The
Establishment they're controlled you
have to know the direction of Faith you
may say Pat what does this have to do
with God this is what it has to do with
god
um
I'm a pretty paranoid guy I'm a
skeptical Guy this is what happens when
you're Middle Eastern you're you
naturally have a hard time for The
Establishment you naturally have a hard
time with Faith Church I was an atheist
for 25 years of my life because I saw
stuff in church and I didn't like it and
I saw stuff on the government I didn't
like it I saw the gamesmanship all this
other stuff here's what I will tell you
um
the more your family and your kids don't
believe in a higher power they will
replace that with another higher power
and that higher power is you when you're
alive but when you die that higher power
could end up being the government when
you're dead
I would much rather have my kids
make the mistake of believing there's a
God and when they die they realize there
isn't then risk my kids not believing
there's a God and they make the
government being the God and then risk
being controlled and we die we're like
shoot there was a God the risk is better
having faith in your life because you
don't fear powerful men men of Faith
Don't Fear The Establishment men of
Faith don't fear dying because they
believe there's afterlife men of Faith
speak in a completely different way than
men of the establishment if there's ever
been a time ever I told you last night
what did I tell you last night at 10
o'clock at night what'd I say to you
last night I said a lot but but the
church part what I say to you go to
Temple go to Temple I'm not even a Jew I
said go to the go to the temple you're
Mormon you're not going to church go to
your church you're Catholic you're not
going to go you're Christian you're not
going to go you're Muslim I don't care
what it is I will much rather have a
person believe in a faith this is is not
a fake debate we need more people
believing in God this great nation of
America the miracle that it ended up
becoming where so many of us have won
and got the rewards of these men and
women who sacrifice that came before us
these men and women
casted a vision that the only thing that
gave him the credit that this is
possible that it can actually happen was
God and then we wake up a 270 year old
company called the United States of
America by the way for a longest time it
was a corporation America was founded as
a federal Corporation as well United
States of America's you can look this up
this this idea
with these men and women that became
what it is today
and other countries that have been
around a lot longer than I than we have
then we beat those guys yeah I don't
think that happens without God so uh uh
if if you believed in Russia collusion
for three years you can definitely start
believing in God you don't have to have
all the facts to want to believe in God
your life's going to be a lot better
you're going to become a better parent
better leader better spouse better
friend better in every possible way
anyways Tom thoughts on this story here
with Wall Street Journal no and by the
way this is not a this is not a this is
a hill story we're talking about here
right this is a hill story so what are
your thoughts on this story well I think
America is still a place of faith when
you compare all those stats to the rest
of the world America is still a place of
faith and I think that if all of us
would turn to our faith tradition I
think we would be treating each other
better I would think that we would be
calling on our the people we elect for
higher standards of Integrity or hell
just to have a standard of integrity and
I
I can't agree with you any more
stridently with what you just said and
how you summed it up that this is the
time to lead your family to leave your
friends to lead your community and
standards of Faith integrity and
character are found in are found in
faith in in big stocks because faith can
drive character character drives people
people that come together and form
organizations called businesses Civic
groups friendships communities so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
thank you